why hello there
youtube and people watching youtube and
other people
hack this thing and watch it some other
way i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for today
june 14th 2021 do me a favor
subscribe to our youtube channel tap the
notification bell
share our videos yada yada we got a big
show for you today i'm feeling good had
a good weekend
pretty much i'm pretty much done with
the second book i had my editor here
for a couple days and we went through
the manuscript
one more time we got a little bit of
finessing we still got to do over the
next couple weeks
and then i will announce the title and
the pre-sale date i don't think we're
going to do a pre-sale
until right before i go off the grid in
july i think the last thing that i'm
going to do is we'll announce the
pre-sale for the new book
which will be out in april 2022
my first book came out in april of 2020.
it's really like
as i talk about all the time you're like
time has stretched and pulled and just
been so freaking weird and the
publishing process in general is very
very slow
uh but i'm really proud of this thing
and i think it's going to show you sort
of the next step
in you know that book defended some
liberal values but what do you do in a
world that has become so anti
liberal i lay it out for you and we'll
have all sorts of
fun bonuses and giveaways and all kinds
of stuff on that front oh and
uh this is just sort of uh hilarious so
my editor
who i've been working with now for like
two years helen she's she's a great girl
over at penguin random house and uh you
know you can imagine how many star wars
references she's had to take out
out of both of my manuscripts like i
think in dover in this book we maybe had
three star wars references but in my
original
manuscript in scribblings it was like
probably at like ten
we're very limiting i think we're only
doing one or two maybe in this book
um but she admitted to me on saturday
she stayed here for a couple days
she admitted to me on saturday at about
five o'clock that she has
never seen star wars my book editor
never seen star wars she wasn't even
really understanding my references
so i was like all right we're gonna have
dinner then we're gonna watch star wars
we had dinner we sit down to watch star
wars
she fell asleep in 15 minutes okay
obi-wan barely made an appearance
these are the people that i'm working
with can you believe that just
unbelievable all right guys we got a big
show for you today
i'm in the mood and oh and then by the
way uh i'm leaving tomorrow i'm going to
miami
for reasons which need not be mentioned
a lot of good stuff actually locals is
moving down
to miami so we're moving the company
down there i'm interviewing uh miami
mayor francis suarez and then i'm doing
a couple other podcasts and there's just
so much happening in the tech scene
down there i think we're going to do a
locals meet up either on wednesday or
friday so if you want to be part of that
join us at reubenreport.locals.com and
of course it's kind of ironic i am
leaving california tomorrow which is
june 15th to go to florida
and tomorrow june 15th happens to be the
day that apparently california is
opening
although now they're saying that gavin
newsom has given himself these emergency
powers that he can basically close us at
any time because this is a bananas place
anyway i'm looking forward to seeing you
guys
in hot and humid florida four stories
for you today first off the g7
is happening across the pond and joe
biden is there and he's old and confused
but don't take my word for it we're
gonna show it to you then there's a
uh news channel called msnbc
it's a propaganda network on your higher
cable channels
i know most of you guys don't have it
already or have it anymore
but there's this woman joy read on there
she's a sort of a paranoid lunatic
and she defended antifa in a very
strange way and then
msnbc selectively edited out the part
that she did that when they put it
online so we're going to show you that
then there's this guy robert reich i've
mentioned him before
he is a former labor secretary i believe
under bill
clinton and he's just become like sort
of just like a crazed
like when you talk about like these
crazed far
left nut bags these people who were once
decent liberals
who maybe if you're conservative you
have some disagreements with and oh i
want to do a little more
with the government or i'm fighting for
this or like that kind of thing
but then has just devolved into sort of
the worst kind of demagogue well he put
up a ridiculous
like just absolutely ridiculous video on
twitter over the weekend
claiming that conservatives and people
on the right don't want anyone to learn
about racism
and that we don't want to teach anyone
critical race but that's really just
teaching anyone
about racism and it's like no that's not
really the truth so
i'll unpack that we've got a quote from
chris rufo who as you know
is doing a bang-up job on exposing these
frauds and then speaking of frauds robin
d'angelo who's one of the prime
purveyors
of critical race theory she gets about
30 grand a pop
when she gives these speeches to guilty
white people well she just gave
a speech and we got some video from
carlin borsenko where
she basically says she admits she's a
racist which is part of the whole
critical race everything that as a white
person you have to admit you're a racist
but she's talking to white people
talking about how she's racist and
they're applauding for her
and i just thought it was worth talking
about but before we get to all that guys
i'm super psyched
to talk about my new sponsor uh i just
got off the phone with them
and these guys they're just freaking
fantastic and i'm going to show you
something in just a sec
i'm really psyched to be welcoming raise
american as a new sponsor to the show a
company
who raises the bar for premier organic
grass-fed beef all over the country for
more than 15 years
raise american has been honing its
processes to provide
lovers of beef the ultimate eating
experience from the feed
to the cattle to the steak raised
american raises the standard of what
american organic beef ought to be
raise american cattle come from humanely
treated animals reared
on small independent american farms
farms run by family farmers and ranchers
adhering to some of the strictest animal
welfare
and sustainable farming protocols
healthy cattle make healthy beef and no
one knows that better than the team at
raise american
raise american focuses on sustainability
which is why they work closely with
these
family farms to raise grass-fed organic
cattle which spend most of their lives
grazing pastures in the fresh open air
grazing in a way that regenerates the
soil instead of depleting it
raise american is 100 organic 100
grass-fed 100
american go to raiseamerican.com right
now to order and learn more
good for you good for our planet good
for america and have you ever heard a
sponsor that is more in line with me i
mean you guys know especially if you're
following me on locals i'm cooking
massive steaks
tomahawks rib eyes filet mignons
porterhouses i love doing this well they
sent me the craziest box of meat
and guys look at the size of the meat
look at my meat my meat is huge okay
this is a huge
huge piece of delicious meat that i will
be cooking for i mean i could feed
i could feed like oh this is probably
like 20 people or something
this is a giant ribeye i've got huge
filet mignons
i'm psyched guys that is a big piece of
meat all right let's do a show uh joe
biden
is the president of the united states
and uh he's an elderly man he's 78 years
old he's oft
confused doesn't know where he is
sometimes and doesn't know what he's
talking about well i've got a video for
you here
at the g7 which pretty much shows both
those traits
where we can work together with russia
for example
uh in uh in libya we should be opening
up
the the the passes to be able to go
through and provide uh
provide food assistance and economic
asses i mean
vital assistance to a population that's
in real trouble
i think i'm going to try very much hard
to
it is by the way there's places where
i shouldn't be starting off and
negotiating in public here but let me
say it this way
russia has engaged in activities which
are we believe are contrary to
international norms
but they have also um
uh bitten off some real problems they're
gonna have trouble chewing on
and for example the rebuilding of
of syria of uh of libya of
you know this is they're there and
as long as they're there without the
ability to bring about some order
in the in the region and you can't do
that very well without
providing for the basic economic needs
of people so i'm hopeful
that we can find an accommodation
that where we can save the lives of
people in for example
in in libya
what what i mean that rambling
meandering
i should have prefaced this all by
telling you guys
when he keeps saying libya there he's
talking about syria
now i get it you could confuse libya and
syria and by the way we did
do what president barack obama called
a kinetic military action in libya
remember when we basically dethroned
libya right we just completely upended
the entire country
that was under barack obama we didn't
get congressional authorization
for that either uh remember that gaddafi
guy he's gone now and libya in essence
is just a failed state but nobody talks
about that
anyway i'm not really showing you this
video because
biden got libya and syria confused
that's not really it it's more the
uh the clear that he doesn't
know what's going on and i have some
sympathy
for a 78 year old man that is being
dragged all over the country and
everyone knows something's wrong with
him
so i'm not doing this on the glib side
of o
biden is whatever he is this is if you
think
other world leaders are watching that or
listening to that and thinking the
united states in
is in good shape i mean to quote joe
biden come on man
like that's not it like there are many
videos there were a couple others from
the weekend where he's just like
puttering off at one point and the media
is trying to ask him questions
and jill and he's like you can watch the
way he walks he's like shuffling his
feet like
like an old man at shady pines and then
the media starts yelling questions and
then jill grabs him no no no not now and
then they just pull him away
and he also does this other thing where
he's like you know uh oh i shouldn't say
this or they don't want me to say this
or i shouldn't give away our secrets now
but he can't control himself which
seemingly is one of the symptoms
of dementia or some early situation
this is not because i'm not saying this
because he's a democrat i'm not saying
this to be
dick dick i'm not saying this to be
anything other than
if joe biden is the president of the
united states well then he's the guy
flying the plane and i want the guy
that's flying the plane to be competent
whether he was the
captain of the plane that i chose or not
and if you think that there's
anyone in the world that is looking at
america right now and thinks that
america is strong
or that that man is competent like our
leaders our
our leaders are failing us our leaders
are failing us if he's the top leader
well then there's a whole other bunch of
leaders and whether they're in the media
or whether they're academic
or whether they're political leaders
they're failing us because what in the
world
is that although the people of libya are
probably happy to hear that they got a
shout out even accidentally because
they're like yeah it would be nice you
know things aren't going so well here
you got rid of gaddafi he wasn't a great
guy
someone literally stuck a knife up his
ass did you guys see that video when the
when the country was collapsing
it's true they chased him down the
street and someone that's how they
killed him
um you know it's seemingly the right way
to go for him but the point is
that like what's happened we we toppled
that country um
and i assume the people of libya are
happy to hear even accidentally that
we're talking about them
all right let's talk about msnbc i know
nobody's really watching this channel
but i think it's important to highlight
the nonsense that the media
puts out there because that way when you
talk to your blue and on friends
who think that antifa is just an idea or
who think
that the america was about to be toppled
on january 6th or whatever
their conspiracy of the day is you you
are armed with some information you can
go oh but you know
the people that you watch are actually
crazy people or
even their own networks edit them
because of some of the nonsense
that they uh spout so anyway this is joy
reads
show uh and you're gonna see
the full thing here you're gonna see the
unedited clip that was played
live on msnbc talking about antifa
and then she offers up a very bizarre
conspiracy theory uh and then
we'll make note of of what exactly they
edited out when they uploaded it
to the internet yeah and angela
completely anticipated my question that
i was gonna have to you clint watts and
i think we've set this up perfectly
because that's the question that i have
as well because before
any of this took place um if and let's
just listen to louis gomer and he if
he's claiming
that he was being told by capital police
officers that there was going to be this
influx of antifa
who they've claimed were basically the
devil they're just anti-fascists they
don't really
show up anywhere if we're seeing in some
of these cases um
where proud boys and and etc are saying
that they anticipated
that antifa would come and fight them
that black lives matter supporters will
come and fight them
so that donald trump could then impose
the insurrection act and they could act
as a militia we're seeing that in some
of the cases
okay so first off i want to read the
craziest part of the quote before i tell
you what msnbc cut there
antifa they're just anti-fascist they
don't really show up anywhere
lady you gotta screw loose okay that's
the nicest way i can put it because
they're burning down portland
and seattle and they've destroyed parts
of los angeles and san francisco
and new york city is becoming dangerous
and many other
blue cities but when the president tells
you that antifa is just an idea and then
this woman says
they don't really show up anywhere
because these people literally have blue
goggles
over their eyes apparently well gateway
pundit found out
that msnbc didn't want everybody to hear
joy's crazy conspiracy theory
uh this is direct from the gateway
pundit msnbc appears to have
stealthily edited a crazy rant from joy
reid in which she spouted a bizarre
conspiracy theory and defended antifa
saying they don't really show up
anywhere the portion of the discussion
is mysteriously not
included in the segment that msnbc
uploaded online
but has been obtained by the gateway
pundit that's what we just showed you
the timestamp was also removed from the
bottom right corner of the screen
of their upload possibly to cover up the
edit it is present in the original clip
in the original version reed is
discussing her bizarre conspiracy theory
that
capital protesters believed they would
be fighting antifa
and black lives matter so that president
donald trump
could impose the insurrection act and
remain in
office so the reason i wanted to do this
was a
just to shed more light on just the
inability
it's not even inability the the direct
and blatant
lies that these people say when they're
talking about antifa so it's not the
inability for them to cover antifa
properly
they actually obfuscate and and
purposely don't want you to see
certain violence because they want you
to see other violence but then she went
on this crazy rant
this sort of made-up rant about that
they were going to have to fight the
proud boys there and then trump would
use the internship
it's just all made up nonsense and we
know about all the nonsense that these
people make up constantly so it's like
if you got a cousin
that's watching msnbc it's like that's
like pretty much dealing with someone in
a mental institution and i don't know
what the best way to do that is like do
you need to
you know meet them for coffee once a
week slightly drug the coffee and then
and then you can get them out over a
course of months
don't please don't quote me on that
that's not you shouldn't be drugging
your blue and on cousin from the mental
institution oh there's the
there's the clip for media matters have
at it guys um
anyway when i talk about lie laundering
this is exactly what lie laundering is
you get an msnbc host
telling you that what you can see
doesn't exist meaning antifa burning
things down
and then what didn't happen is really
the important thing meaning that
proud boys were going to show up and
that trump then would use the fighting
for the insurrection act that's a thing
that
did not happen but that's what she's
really focused on as opposed to the
things
that do happen and even the executives
at bananas msnbc thought that was
too crazy to air which is why they cut
it
change the time and everything else
which is just so consistent
which how which with which the uh
mainstream media and corporate press
works okay let's talk about this guy
robert right
so you know i don't tweet on the
weekends i don't tweet on the weekends
thus
when i come back on monday mornings and
i'm catching up on things it's just like
a three-day flood basically because i
try to end the day you know midday
friday so i get like half a friday
uh you know i'm still working but like
you know just not on twitter half a
friday saturday sunday
get back on monday morning and it's just
like a two and a half day flood of
insanity
that i get to see that i missed over the
weekend and by the way i highly
recommend
that you guys do the no twitter or
or no social media or limit it in some
way
on the weekend thing try one little
thing i mean i recommend this in the
book but like try one little thing which
is at least don't even
don't bring your phone into your room on
the weekends how about that much like
don't wake up
with the first thing that you see in the
morning about the news or the craziness
and of course the last thing that in the
previous night the news and the general
state of craziness anyway on mondays
the flood just starts again so this is
video posted on twitter of robert wright
he's the former
labor secretary under bill clinton and
he was sort of a clinton democrat this
is what i would call
a moderate liberal 20 years ago which is
probably very similar to what i was 20
years ago
and unfortunately because progressivism
is a mind virus as you know it gets into
the system so it gets into a guy like
this who is once a decent liberal
the liberals because they don't believe
in some sort of outer truth
the the virus in essence just gets in
them destroys all their faculties and
then they just say nonsense and endless
lies much like
joy read in the clip that we just showed
so this is robert reich
talking about critical race theory but
really really
really listen to what he says and then
we will
unpack it after but just listen to his
words and you tell me
does his words match up with what you
know
critical race theory to be the so-called
party of free speech
is now going after academic freedom a
host of republican-controlled states
have passed or are
gearing up to pass bills that ban
teaching
the role race has played in the history
of american politics
policy and law conservatives lobbed the
term critical race theory against the
nation's tragic racial history they
don't want students to know
calling it indoctrination or
brainwashing well as an educator i can
tell you
that the real indoctrination in
brainwashing is in leaving
out this history and only teaching
children the myths
that we've always been a perfect country
always lived up to our ideals and
there's no need to reckon
with our past that's robert reich
i'll say this directly to you and we'll
post it on the twitter
you're a liar and a buffoon and a fraud
no republicans are saying don't
teach our racial history we do teach our
racial history
i think some people could argue at a
disproportionate level
we teach our racial history in all of
our public schools and certainly all of
our private schools it's taught
everywhere no one's saying don't teach
racial
history no one's saying don't teach an
honest assessment of the history of the
united states including
racial issues people are saying don't
put raci
race essentialism into the schools don't
teach children
that they are born racist and to see
everything through a racial lens
and that things like showing up on time
and
hard work are tools of being white
that is actually kind of racist but you
can't
even honestly assess what the other
people are saying i'm taking your words
for what they are and showing you that
it's nonsense you are saying
nobody want that the republicans don't
want people to be taught about race or
an honest assessment of history that is
a complete lie
you are a liar but don't just take my
word for it
chris ruffo who as you guys know is one
of the leading
legal experts fighting critical race
theory in all of these states he's one
of the guys that are getting these
states
to push out the ideas of critical race
theory not to say you can't teach
about racism and slavery which we all
learned in high school
did anyone not learn in junior high in
high school about about racism about
slavery
everyone did no one's saying you can't
learn about that that's what these
idiots
are claiming we're saying but it's not
true but chris ruffo who has brought
many of these lawsuits
to say you just can't indoctrinate
children and and tell children that
they're guilty
over the color of their skin which of
course they are not guilty over the
color of their skin
well rufo replied to robert reich he
said i used to respect you
but this is a flat out lie none of the
bills
limiting teaching none of the bills
limit teaching about racism
they prohibit teachers from being racist
by promoting race essentialism
collective guilt
and racial superiority theory to
students your lie is transparent
and pathetic and yes that is completely
right everything robert reich
said there is a lie okay absolute lie
note he didn't quote anything
from any of the laws that are trying to
be passed in these states he just
said his idea of it right and this is
what they do
with everything this is how progressives
win they say these
vague things that sort of kind of sound
right oh and then
the average person who's trying to live
their life is like oh my god
the conservatives don't want people to
learn about race they must be such
racist
and then of course it's absolutely
not true and and by the way this isn't
the first time
that robert reich has done this uh watch
this video that he put up on prageru
this is from like a month or two ago
uh criticized he put this up on twitter
criticizing
prageru gregory u is the most insidious
outfit advancing the wright's online
agenda and that's saying something
it's five minute videos which have
collected nearly five
billion views couch typical republican
dog whistles
and outright misinformation with titles
like
the myth of voter suppression they serve
as a gateway to the more overt
right-wing content pushed by the likes
of ben shapiro
and stephen crowder prageru pushes its
videos into
schools over six thousand teachers and
parents have signed up so far
and social media's algorithms amplify
all this misinformation
when prageru's videos are assigned by
teachers for students to watch
at home more right-wing content comes up
for kids on social media
and youtube and it's spreading around
the world
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu even used
one of prageru's videos to justify the
actions of the israeli military
backed by fracking billionaires dan and
paris wilkes
and other right-wing billionaires
prageru deploys a 25 million
a year budget with with ads targeting
young people with right-wing propaganda
schools the internet and now even
far-right leaders abroad
this organization is advancing its
right-wing ideology everywhere
so the next time you see these videos
know the truth about who's really
behind them uh the next time you see
this guy on video know the truth
of what a douchebag he is i mean notice
he didn't have any specific
critique it's all these vague
generalities about what
prageru does just like the vague
generalities about what critical race
theory does so what did he say there
typical dog whistles and then he shows
some titles of videos he doesn't
critique any of the ideas in the videos
but the dog whistles or the titles okay
well do you want to criticize any of the
ideas around
voter fraud or anything else no you
didn't want to do that because that's
not the bumper sticker thing got it
right
and then this is this is very very scary
do you guys realize that these
five-minute animated videos
are a gateway to orthodox jew yarmulke
wearing ben shapiro
you get it he could yeah the next thing
you know you'll be eating holla on
friday okay i mean it's just
and that stephen crowder guy oh my god
oh my god you start watching prager you
i mean where's the shout out i mean i
guess that's what this is really about
it's like rike
i've got three of i think the top 20
prageru videos in terms of use it's like
i've radicalized people come on man give
me a little credit over here
and then of course netanyahu
used a video to defend israel now again
you didn't criticize any of the ideas in
the video but
this is what progressives do with
everything
that is a paranoid lunatic who should
probably
seek mental health like i don't i
honestly don't know how to describe it
anymore
than this like when you see someone like
joy reid
who is will not tell you that antifa is
burning down cities when you see people
like this man
who are completely delusional it's just
this idea and then you're gonna watch
this the next thing you know you're
watching ben shapiro before you know it
you're a white supremacist from an
orthodox jew it's all
so stupid but they they keep making
these videos
so all i guess we can do
is expose these people over and over i
should show you my response when he
originally
put out that tweet i responded when he
put out that video about prageru
i said i don't normally share these
nonsensical things but check this
lol worthy hysteria by another
paranoid authoritarian woke loon ben
shapiro is scary
and stephen crowder believes in limited
government we'll discuss
further at our evil right-wing dinner
tomorrow dennis prager
and it's true i had dennis prager over
for dinner a couple weeks ago
with about 20 other people nobody was
radicalized as far as i could tell
uh although he did smoke cigars at the
end and i was rattling my clothes stunk
so after i was slightly radicalized
after
because i was like i can't sit next to
people with cigar smoke it's gross
anyway these people they're just
ridiculous like these are not serious
people
but think about it that man was the
labor secretary under bill clinton and
and it gets
to what i said earlier this thing about
what happened to the good liberals
what happened to these people who were
somewhat sane and this is why you got to
admire
the parasite that is wokism you got to
admire something that can completely
rot the brain of somewhat otherwise
sensible people it's just
absolutely extraordinary and speaking of
rotting of the brain let's talk about
robin d'angelo she is one of the premier
pushers of critical race theory
and that everything in america is based
in white supremacy and that we're all
racist
and evil and all of this other absolute
drivel nonsense and of course she
herself is white and you're not going to
believe this guys
she's made a tremendous amount of money
telling white people that they're racist
she gets 30 grand
a pop for a speech i've given a lot of
speeches in my day i've never got 30
grand so
actually maybe i just need a better
agent or i need to
start talking to guilty white people i
talk to people regardless of the color
of their skin
and is what it is anyway uh this video
is from
my friend carlin borsenko she got video
of robin d'angelo
talking this is 2018
at a seattle public library a white
woman
talking to white progressives about how
racist
she and all of them are so um i'm pretty
sure i'm speaking to a room filled with
white progressives
when i do a caucus group or something
and the white people are afraid i might
think they're racist
i think you're racist
because i i think i am too right white
progressives can be the most difficult
for people of color
why progressives do indeed uphold and
perpetrate racism
when i first applied to be that
diversity trainer back in the early 90s
i
i thought well of course i'm qualified
to lead uh discussions on racism i'm a
vegetarian
and let me just say that you know i love
seattle
and everything i learned about white
fragility i learned here working with
white progressives
so and this of course is the first thing
that tends to trigger white fragility
generalizing about white people i i know
white people really well
i don't actually think uh young people
today are less racist
in fact uh they're getting worse
so i'm gonna i'm just gonna put it right
out here as a result of being born and
raised as a white person in this culture
i have a racist worldview
i have deep racist biases i have
developed racist patterns
lady get help i mean jesus you've got a
lot of problems
i'm not racist i don't care about the
color of anyone's skin i want everybody
to
be treated equally you obviously are
racist
your entire world view your entire ethos
is a guilt around your own skin color
and then projecting that guilt
onto other sort of pathetic white
liberals and this is the biggest mind
virus eating western society
in 2020 in modern times she's bananas
that i'm sorry look we've done four
stories today i talked about biden he's
got issues that's pretty obvious
joy reid she's a mental case uh uh
who's the other one oh robert i mean
this guy's got problems and then this
one but do you see what happens it's all
because these were once decent people
these were joe biden was once a decent
guy he really was a long time ago and
now he's
compromised and marginalized for many
other reasons joy reid i well i said i
can't say that she was once the i don't
know enough about her
actually if you go back like 10 years
ago she had a lot of very very anti-gay
writing and a bunch of really radical
stuff so i can't say she was once decent
but reich was once kinda halfway decent
and this deangelo woman i don't know was
she always racist were her parents
racist were her grandparents racist
she would argue yes she would argue that
by the color of their skin they were all
racist
but these people who as gad said says
are just
self-flagellating all the time and
whipping themselves and i'm so
and the way the audience laughs i'm a
white racist you're a white racist
who what a world people
what a world all right i'm heading to
florida tomorrow so actually right after
this we are
taping a q a for tomorrow so that way
you get a show tomorrow so if you want
to submit a question
you can do that right now at
reubenreport.locals.com
we just put up part one i did a mini
interview a 20 minute interview with
chelsea mitchell this girl is a track
star
track high school and college track star
in connecticut
and you're not going to believe this
suddenly they started letting biological
boys
into all of the track events that she
was part of and the boys were beating
all the girls yes these were
boys who had transitioned to become
girls and the boys were all winning so i
talked to her and her lawyer because
uh they wrote a piece in usa today and
that usa today kind of threw them under
the bus it's re
really really interesting and just like
a really interesting vignette related to
everything going on in the world
uh yes i will be doing a locals meet up
in miami
we're going to either do that on
wednesday or friday i've got something
on thursday so we'll figure that out
and you know i've i just checked the
weather in miami this week it's going to
be very hot and humid so the hair is
going to be a little bit lower due to
the humidity and i apologize in advance
uh and then we will not have live shows
for the rest of the week but we've got a
bunch of interviews going up and all
sorts of good stuff
anyway i hope this was a was a good
start to your week as you can see i've
got a big piece of meat i'm dealing with
a lot of crazy people
close to finishing my book my editor
hasn't you know watched star wars i got
a lot of stuff to think about
anyway enjoy the rest of the day i'll
see you tomorrow